welcome to the real rejects I'm Greg
habla this is John Roca how are you
doing at the outlaw nation John yes go
check out his channel outlaw nation
Shawn ruckus says link in description
box and pin comment he has been killing
it on the youtubes thing I've seen a few
of his videos so far some of the best
live streams you'll catch overall it's a
wonderful dude and I love chatting with
you whenever I would go to like Schmo
down or any countless events you're one
of the few people who feels like a real
friend thank you tell me more I'm gonna
now take jabs and all the other people
who don't make me feel accepted thank
you for being you these you always been
awesome and thanks for helping me get
this channel up on the air it's been
it's been great that's gonna rebel Reese
all I'm waiting for is for you to just
throw that back thank you I have a
purpose have you heard of the channel
new rock stars yes yeah I've heard of it
a lot actually they have some of the
best breakdown videos and they have this
video called spider-man new Easter Egg
Toby returning and I've been seeing on
Twitter that there's all this talk about
a possibility with Tobey Maguire coming
back as spider-man I think a lot has to
do with the Sam Raimi doing strange too
and I think in one of the spider-man
movies they even drop the Doctor Strange
name at one point I think what they're
coming up with like doc Ock's name who's
Sam Raimi's brother like actual brother
Ted Raimi Ted Raimi yeah its head Raimi
character the assistant character right
I think he says doctor said anyway so
there's all this talk going around I've
been wanting something wire to come back
in this weird universe so I thought
let's watch this new rockstars video
since you guys know I love this channel
so freaking let's do it right producing
the new spider-man they kind of have
joint custody of home
[Music]
yeah sure of course
the promise of interconnectivity the
pikeys friendly freak show has been a
huge success for Sony so the candy ghost
I can see the live link Bolger we're
also going to give these background
criminal spider-man to remind us of how
far from home and then all in order to
make the limbs for Peter Parker the
focus for the next spider-man film in
summer 2021 and
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
shut up Kyle hey we worked with them
Humphry where's is Bezeq originally
backpack everywhere Ridge wallet looks
good rich products are great please
let's not talk at all about the
spider-man stuff let's talk about the
product placement in this video and
promote the rich and hopes they sign
back up with us to do another shadow I
liked what they presented so far this
possibility of the connection spider-man
and the multiple spider-man's behind you
know I wonder was gonna mention Doctor
Strange at some point in this whole
thing whoa because boss logic did that
awesome thing where they showed Tobey
Maguire spider-man coming out of one of
those portals yeah pretty cool well
after this product placement yeah let's
see sorry for talking all over my
suppose that was both you and I won't
put all the blame on you their talk so
much about rage on this channel
Wow flows right into it hey was that
Kyle no I'm sorry it was Harry Potter
boss Eric's good at this
sorry okay yeah do that music
right and perhaps in this rainy verse
mix gratitude toward Peter honey think
about multiple versions of spider-verse
awesome right it makes a lot of sense
May and July why I gotta get sense like
that to do my shows
gasps that's old to get a discord I'm
learning how to use this that's great a
lot of knowledge there I love their
videos yeah I really do mister Roca I
really do give us something to aspire to
gives you something to aspire don't get
in my ego I'm just sayin
geez I like coming around any reason
having them come true so I enjoyed that
very much from Eric Eric Voss the class
sorry I do have a friend named Carl who
looks a lot like anyway um yeah I mean
within the multiverse ii they pointed
out the Daily Bugle logo looking the
same yeah that just blew my mind because
it was like the spider-man one with the
outfit that we all saw on the
the wall and the trailer I don't really
consider it like oh it this is the Tobey
Maguire one I thought it was just a
paying tribute thing to that but then to
have the Daily Bugle logo which is not
something most fans will notice or catch
yeah they showed the Sun I'm like okay
what's the big deal
that excites me because I like that
theory because I've been wanting them to
honestly I've been wanting them to do
some special spider-man movie where they
cross over Andrew Garfield Tobey Maguire
and Tom Hall and all in one movie even
if Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield
just show up for like a you know a few
minutes there be such a cool thing to
see on screen and with what Sony has
established with spider-verse it's
something I totally want I guess the
trailer itself is maybe trying to
disillusion us just a little bit yeah
because you do see vulture there and
then you see the murderer logo so that
makes you go this must take place after
far from home and that's what's going on
with spider-man and maybe vulture broke
out a prison or something like that but
the idea of kind of combining a little
bit of alternate universe some prequel
stuff I don't know bottom line is most I
got from this video was that would be
insane if Tobey Maguire is able to
return for a little bit of a cameo and
open up the idea of multiple versus did
you watch the crisis on Infinite Earths
yeah yeah of course
you know how they went way out of their
way yeah to make everything you've ever
seen from DC is connected somehow they
connected yeah and I get the impression
that's kind of what they're aiming for
here now if this theory happens to be
true with combining multiverse of
madness and you know the venom world in
the spider version yeah well this could
have been the the reason why Derek said
left foot creative differences because
he maybe thought I don't want my dog to
strange being used as a vehicle I kind
of wrap up all these storylines with
spider-man or bring all these spider-man
in maybe he didn't feel that that was
true to the character that he wanted to
do or the next story you wanted to tell
so you bring in someone like Sam Raimi
makes all the sense of when I said this
on geek buddies last night one of my
shows all my channel is one of my friend
Shannon I was like I'm saying Sam Raimi
coming back this makes sense only if
then finding a way to kind of close that
loop between the Sam Raimi at spider-man
because people have that negative
feeling about spider-man 3
joked about in spider-verse name and
Feige used to work with Raimi so they
have in a previous relationship so maybe
this is his way of going like once you
come on help make this all happen
bring all the spider-man's in Garfield
Tobey Maguire he'll maybe we'll get your
and Lowenthal who's the voice of
spider-man in the ps4 game to come in
and do something to be kind of cool
maybe a shot of them playing the game
while they're walking by or some people
playing the game with or walking by all
of that is possible here and then it all
works overall if they go with a prequel
that's interesting because we don't know
where it is in time right just because
it's a prequel doesn't mean it doesn't
come forward in time eventually telling
that story with more bees if it's a
sinister six Morbius is well known of
playing both sides of the fence he's an
antihero he's been a villain he's
initially a villain in the comics and
becomes a hero and an ally of spider-man
so all of that could play out as well
but I love the idea of jin jonah jameson
being involved in this and anyway she
yeah cuz JK Simmons is fantastic and I
love this I would love to see if - J
jonah Jameson Oh
would be great and I think Kraven the
hunter is a proper next time yeah I
remember growing up on the 90 show and a
little bit before Morbius was truly
Morbius there was a storyline with
Kraven the hunter and the crave and like
wife doctor late it's been a long time
yeah some of her experiments led to when
Spiderman had the six arms yeah and
Morbius is blood and all that so it just
feels like a natural tie-in I still want
them to build to a point where you do
get horror spider-man with a six off
everything they're talking about here
really does excite me I guess the thing
is if it is treated as an alternate
universe - the Tobey Maguire version why
is he being labeled as a murderer
because there was nothing yeah and it
off in spider-man 3 right that lets well
Gwen Stacy dies in spider-man 3 right
doesn't she Ron Howard's daughter she's
Gwen sting sighs doesn't she die in the
movie or no and she just presented in
the movie she's just in the mood well
baby that's the intro Garfield 1 Gwen
Stacy dies in his second one that's for
yeah
so I mean their spider-man has deaths on
his sleep let me just tell you that's
look at his resume there are
that's on that resume okay well that's
fair so who knows maybe they're all mad
that any Brock is dead yeah was it
anymore he was so wonderful but all of
it I love the idea and you're right
that's the one kind of drawback in this
whole thing is how can it's a murderer
who would you've murdered in that time
oh I think just bottom line I mean did
you not like the Raimi versions of one
and two I like one or two I don't think
they hold up as strongly as some people
say so I'm gonna to is the best of the
three absolutely doesn't hold up as much
as you would think nowadays still a damn
good movie some of the CGI is a little
wonky but their version of Doc Ock was
fantastic yeah you know that's what I
would say I do I still look considerate
one of the bet my favorite complet
movies personally my hair movie fight
you yeah jerk god no not again how dare
you have a different opinion bottom line
it did not conclude the no Raimi stir
and like those were ten poll films those
were important films in terms of
superhero cinema right and I still see
articles about the Spider Man forward
that could have been yeah don't really
hear that about like amazing spider-man
3 you know everyone's kind of cool with
letting out for the most part but
whatever version of Tobey Maguire even
bringing back Kirsten Dunst perhaps as
Mary Jane Watson oh yeah I just think it
would be cool if there was some way
opening up this portal that we got
something to conclude it if it was like
10 minutes just to wrap up the button on
them like Oh Mary Jane and Peter Parker
live happily ever after they had a kid
or something just any anything to close
it out and be like okay we were able to
you know finalize this and put a button
on it
you know I think well the great things
he brought up to it was the writer of
the Loki stuff from Disney Plaza is
going to be involved in this multiverse
of madness movie as well right so maybe
he's the one that understands how Feige
is trying to connect everything TV into
film so he's got all the storylines
roaming around and make sure everything
kind of lines up so that both Morbius
and the new spider-man from all kind of
link up with Doctor Strange films so
that's all possible maybe they'll use
the multiverse of madness to make the
Netflix ones really tie in better oh
that would be cool well
okay yeah well you stand excited you're
not gonna be a Scot Darris no whatsoever
ideas are gone different crisis on
Infinite Earths anyway guys what do you
think about these theories which one
stands true to you the most do you want
Tobey Maguire to return please say yes
please
maybe if you say yes Kevin Feige will
say yes subscribe to new rock stars if
you haven't done so already subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
will get notified whenever we got a
video I'll check out John or okay John
rogas says outlaw nation on his YouTube
channel he's dude last but not least pay
true to the day's shut up Jay t c JT
when I speak with this guy messages he's
got a lot to express sometimes when we
with Google hangout with him could be a
little bit more on the timid side but he
wants to direct so here's my thing of
why I want to shout him out in this
video I feel like there are most likely
multiple verses of JT all Japanese from
Hawaii I mean one of them could be like
you know from an interracial parentage
not likely likely each one is just a
different shade of JT one is a horndog
who would get me to Dan our universe the
other one is like the mother Teresa of
Japanese men from Hawaii yes that's a
hard to fill position
he's called mother JT Risa and then you
got another one who is a motivational
speaker and then you got another one who
is a homeless guy and you've got another
one who is a stripper and he goes by
Jade why do you make everything that
gianni now we're just going to take a
yellow dollar bill signs cuz of your
twisted mentality what if I meant that
he's one who makes comic strips do you
think YouTube is gonna listen to this
amount of detail that's a pg-13 concept
they show it on network television and
there's another universe where JT
fix the YouTube algorithm thank you for
being you JT